these are live pictures from the US from  Capitol Hill Washington DC where the  hearing is set to begin shortly after  more than a month of closed-door  testimony the hearing is just minutes  from being broadcast live around the  world it centers around a phone call  between President Trump and Ukraine's  leader  Vladimir's olenski in July the first  witnesses up are two veteran diplomats  acting US ambassador to Ukraine William  Taylor and Deputy Assistant Secretary of  State George Kent a tailor has said in  closed-door testimony he had what he  calls a clear understanding the Trump  wanted to pressure Ukraine into  investigating his political rival Joe  Biden in exchange for continuing  military aid to Ukraine  Kent testified the Trump's lawyer Rudy  Giuliani pushed for the removal of the  former US ambassador to Ukraine Murray  Ivanovich who will testify on Friday the  president denies any wrongdoing and says  the inquiry is in his words the greatest  witch hunt in American history